so without further ado here is conan
[Music]
o'brien
what
thank you
oh okay come on okay please
thank you no that's too much
i haven't even spoken yet
thank you thank whoa oh my god
that's crazy
all right thank you thank you please
please let's begin
greetings graduates faculty parents
relatives zoom bombers and the true
heroes today
the harvard i.t department really nice
compression guys
beautiful very very little buffering
nice job nerds
welcome to harvard's first online
graduation
and congratulations to the harvard class
of 2020.
yes i want to begin
by telling you that the administration
has given me
only 10 minutes to speak today instead
of the traditional 20.
i promise to do my best since everyone's
in such a big hurry
to get back to doing absolutely nothing
i'd like to take just a moment to thank
harvard college for bestowing upon me
an honorary degree doctorate of humane
letters
and philosophy i am truly
truly honored i'd also like to thank
harvard
for a doctorate honoring my
groundbreaking work
in bosonic string theory and condensed
matter physics
thank you thank you i worked with a
great team thank you all
seniors i know you belong in the
turcentenery theater right now
believe me all of us miss harvard yard
i mean where else can you find two
competing pro communist newsletters
written in dothraki
all while signing a petition to ban hot
dogs and donuts for promoting cisgender
identities what a rare and unusual place
but trust me we are taking steps to make
today's commencement
feel as authentic as possible in fact
right now
harvard is charging each of you 50 for
parking in cambridge
yeah plus harvard will see to it that
within the next hour
one of your grandparents will be hit in
the head with a stray frisbee
and be assured one day in the future you
will return
to your alma mater but for now you get
to enjoy me speaking to you from my
backyard
harvard has been graduating students for
nearly 400 years
this is the first one where the
commencement speaker is standing on a
spot
where his dog urinated seven minutes ago
right over here this area yes
yes this commencement will be very
different as you sit here today
or stand or microwave a burrito
or ride a peloton or recline
uncomfortably in your childhood bed
or mine bitcoin or google who is conan
o'brien
you are witnessing many many firsts
in today's ceremony for example
normally graduates would greet and shake
hands
with their faculty deans but now that
shaking hands is a class d felony
those faculty members decided instead to
give you a
virtual butt bump on tick tock
yeah and by the way congratulations to
the department heads
you really captured what cotton mather
was all about
in another first this year harvard has
discarded traditional grading and
switched
to a pass fail system that's right as a
result
several members of the lacrosse team
will graduate
and finally for the first time all of
you will receive your diplomas by mail
now to make sure those diplomas are not
stolen from your porch by package
thieves
they will be mailed to you in a plain
brown wrapper labeled
cornell university diploma
it's foolproof no one's touching that
thing
now i know for all of you this is not
the graduation ceremony you're expecting
right now your parents are realizing
they spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars
just to watch you basically graduate
from an online university
in fact this speech is being simulcast
right now to the university of phoenix
yeah phoenix
minutes phoenix gets it done yeah
they get it done in two years not four
[Music]
anyway i know what some of you are
wondering right now
how could conan at his age possibly
relate to me
well to you i say do not think of me as
someone who graduated harvard 35 years
ago
think of me as a fellow classmate a
fellow classmate
who looks like somehow kind of
wrinkled and bloated at the same time
very hard to do
you see i have some experience as a
graduation speaker
20 years ago i told the graduating
harvard students to break out of their
cocoon and take chances well
20 years later i'd like to amend that
slightly and say
stay in your cocoon stay the cocoon stay
in it
i had no idea about the virus and to you
students who moved back home to a blue
state
please continue to be patient we're a
face mask outside and trust in science
to those of you who move back home to a
red state
i'll see you guys tonight at applebee's
get those onion rings so do not despair
this online ceremony but
celebrate it you have been handed two
choices
use the trial of this global pandemic as
the inspirational launching pad to a
greater destiny
or two go the trump route and blame all
your problems on the previous graduating
class
come on who's with me damn you class of
damn you to hell if nothing else just
make that a t-shirt
damn you do hell 2 000 that's that's a
seller
that moves that's merch that moves
i realize i've said many foolish things
to you today
it's kind of what i do but i would like
to be sincere
before i spoke today i really did give
you
the class of 2020 serious thought and
i'm honestly stunned by what you've
endured in your short lives for my
harvard class 9 11 came
in midlife but i was thinking about it
you came into consciousness
while our nation was still smoldering
from that attack
and you've only known a world beset by
terrorist hate
you've grown up with mass shootings and
school lockdowns
horrors completely absent from my
childhood
you have now witnessed two economic
meltdowns of stunning proportions
you are actually living in a hotter and
more treacherous biosphere
than the one i was born into two months
into your freshman year many of you
voted for the first time
in the 2016 election and ever since
you've been living in the most polarized
united states since the civil war
now this you know all too well
you've been handed more than your share
tom brokaw famously
hailed the people who survived the great
depression and world war ii
not because of who they were as much as
what they endured
he called them the greatest generation
now we don't know
what you will be called because the
generation that cleaned up the mess
left by those a-hole boomers doesn't
just roll off the tongue
you've been challenged your entire lives
and you've demonstrated
one of the most precious qualities one
can have
resilience now cynics like to mock the
supposedly spoiled or kalo youth
of the new millennia but you have seen
and survived so much
and you've responded with wit creativity
righteous anger activism and a gritty
determination
to take the reality you've been handed
and make it better look at you
ten weeks ago you were told to leave
your dorms immediately
get your stuff get out something no one
has said to me since my first marriage
and since that day you have found ways
to stay
safe under absurd and confusing
circumstances
and one way or the other your hard-won
resilience has gotten you
here today to your tv or phone or tablet
or smart watch
to graduate from harvard come hell or
high water
as the father of two teenage children i
look at all you've achieved
in a frightful world and it gives me
great hope
you are remarkable examples to my
children
of how to be smart brave and yes
resilient in a scary world
my generation was always embarrassed to
admit we went to harvard
for fear of bragging but you class of
have earned the right to be proud of
your great accomplishment
the next time someone asks you where you
went to college
hold your head high look them square in
the eye and say
two miles south of tufts
today is unusual in two respects first
as i've said this iconic 384 year old
ceremony is online
and we are strangely separate on a day
that's supposed to embody
community second and more important
today is unusual because at this
commencement
you commence nothing you
and your uniquely tested peers your
generation
commenced long ago while the rest of us
were busy complaining about the sopranos
finale
i have nothing to give you that you
don't already have
and have had for a very long time what i
can offer
is my boundless admiration my deepest
respect
my gratitude for working so hard and
bringing such honor to your families
your faculty and your alumni
our current troubles will pass and you
will laugh
and thrive and experience great joy i
cannot wait
to see what you find people will
accomplish and i know that one day
years from now one of you will stand
where i stand
here in my backyard
and i will have you arrested for
trespassing
thank you
[Applause]
you